be safe out there if you on them streets
man because anything could happen
i remember one time i passed out at an
intersection
and i'm unconscious dude you know or
mentally unconscious i think it's called
and i've been drinking and you know and
also was operating a motor vehicle
and uh and instead of driving i guess i
just
went to sleep at a stoplight and then an
officer showed up
knocked on my window puts a flashlight
on me i wake up
he goes um did you see two wolves out
here fighting
and i was like what the [ __ ] bro
you think i see wolves man and i was
like nah
no sir you know no sir no sir i didn't
see any sir
and he said that somebody called it in
he goes okay well if you see any let us
know and then he [ __ ]
left me bro he left and i was up now and
so i drove i drove home
and i don't even know what that was
about oh just be careful driving here we
go i'm just sitting
on your front porch wondering how could
i be so
far from my home
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been